alright shall we get started I think
we're all here so I'm about to do a
presentation on the subject of visual
programming languages and tools which is
something a bit exotic to bring to a
conference such as this where everybody
speaks to each other in C++ but I think
if you're here it's a good sign that
you're interested or know something
about it I'm curious to know more I'm
set from eggs design I'm lead designer
there we focus a lot on professional
tools and professional tools bring
specific demands in terms of design and
development so let's look at what I'll
be covering firstly a short background
in terms of contextualizing how we deal
with rapid prototyping as a concept and
a method how I got drawn to visual
programming languages and then
recovering the why the when and the how
of using rapid prototyping in digital
design workflows and then I will dive
into real-time prototyping covering some
of the tools worth looking into focus on
one in particular called touch designer
and show some real-world and research
examples I'll be trying to do a few
demos let's see how that goes in terms
of time is it for well developers who
might be interested in rapid rapid
prototyping for software who are curious
about visual programming languages
interested in learning about
multidisciplinary work because that's
how we work at eggs with developers
designers in tandem who wonder how
designers think if you didn't know
already I think we worried a bit
different and that's one of the reasons
for this talk
project managers tech consultants
everyone in between
so let's get to rapid prototyping at
eggs design a bit of context when we
talk about design we usually visualize
it using this pyramid of offerings at
one level or at the bottom you will
probably see what is traditionally
understood as design which is form and
craft how things look but there's much
more to it that we deal with more and
more creative problem-solving and
strategic transformation which can have
quite a wide impact on businesses and
within that there's a certain number of
offerings and you will see rapid
prototyping among form and craft so what
we call rapid prototyping it comes from
really term from industrial design which
we do also have we call it an economical
and pragmatic approach to test and feel
your digital or physical product early
we deal with both industrial design and
digital and service and I would just
highlight those top words economical
because it's cheap and pragmatic because
it's a shortcut to trying out ideas
testing and feeling because it's about
trying to convey the experience of the
final product but how did I get into
visual programming tools and languages
first off when I was working for
projection design then Barco and I have
a colleague he undershoot presented
yesterday or ex-colleague I started
dealing with problems such as pushing
massive amount of pixels to multiple
screens and the traditional tools would
not cut it so I turned to visual
programming languages to be able to do
that because of flexibility and
performance actually then that Nordic
Media Lab company in Halton I we had a
client called a smart systems where a
lot of
quite demanding visualizations were
needed for over there we're looking at a
graph or a consumption generation and
storage marked against the movement of
the Sun and that also brought me to
visual programming languages to be able
to do that from the data that was
getting in from engineers who were very
specific about what the data should look
like
same thing for data dashboards because
of the connectivity that I was able to
get through some of these tools I was
able to inject in real-time data coming
from sensors or at least simulated until
we did get the data the hard part is to
actually just get that real-time
connectivity so it got involved in
real-time development because of that
but I am essentially a designer I'm not
here to disguised as a developer just to
make that straight but why why prototype
at all I usually use a cartoon that
illustrates the first point of
prototyping which is a parable about
making a tree swing this is what
marketing suggested what management
approved what was designed by
engineering what was manufactured in the
end what maintenance installed but this
is actually what the customer wanted and
this is what the customer needed so one
point that idea puts across is if a
picture is worth a thousand words then a
prototype is worth a thousand meetings
and I think if a prototype manages to
create a more accurate vision of what
the final product should be then a lot
has been achieved already and it's worth
the short and quick investment so the
first point about why prototype is
communication
the connection between designers and
developers is achieved much earlier
giving both the same work to work
towards the same goal it helps with
problem definition and redefinition
because while you're doing it you
uncover all sorts of usability issues
and things that you might need to take
up with developers who will be
implementing it I think it fuels
ideation because it enables you to think
while you're doing it and that's that's
a good thing because you are working in
a simulated environment but that's why
you prototype usability testing to test
as early as possible with users whether
your ideas are viable and provide a good
user experience I think it helps to
focus development where the there's more
ground needing to be covered it helps us
assess that very early and a bit of a
bonus is the fact that sometimes
prototyping actually helps a lot with
pitching the idea making the project
exists in the first place so when to use
it well early the thing is the the
design process is less sequential than
before this is the classic loop and any
new variable that comes into play can
cause uncertainty and you might make
assumptions that are dangerous and then
that find their way through the
development stages to the final product
which can cause problems in the end but
the thing is that static designs that we
use a lot as well lack many important
properties of the user experience namely
interaction per se motion multimedia
capabilities device connectivity and
functionality not the least the thing
about being able to do rapid prototyping
is that you can shortcut a lot of these
stages a lot of designers who are
learning to use some of these tools are
eager to try out new ideas very quickly
and that is a good thing I think because
you can get very quickly to test an idea
and see if it is viable in other words
prototypes are the fastest way between
you and your customers
but how to develop prototypes I suppose
in our different lines of work we all
have our different techniques but in
terms of design there is a bit of a
matrix to take into consideration which
marries functionality to visual detail
it's all about how much functionality do
you want how much visual detail you
might want all of it but that's not
always possible so different tools have
different abilities in terms of accuracy
I would describe sort of throughout the
classic design process the level of
fidelity as increasing as you go along
from sketches to wireframes to mock-up
student prototypes and then the end the
only thing distancing prototypes from
from production is the finished level
really how accurate do you need it
well with rapid prototyping we're
starting to compress the process and
trying to achieve a higher level of
fidelity faster short of actually
developing the damn thing but with
real-time prototyping we're mashing it
up because it's all quite layered so
that we are able to really compress the
process and get immediate feedback so
for his real-time prototyping really in
my own words which you can try to shoot
down real-time prototyping is done by
using visual programming tools where
compiling happens on the fly so the
tools that I'm showing in this category
are always running the results of what
you're doing is always being rendered or
displayed or enacted on
and within the rapid prototyping 2
category there this is not an exhaustive
recap but there's many out there going
from quite static basic clickable
screens to tools that are collaborative
tools that are layer based our app based
tools that are stronger in animation
tools it a better for complex systems
it's actually very difficult to put this
in a matrix and make a neat
categorization I tried I started for
this and I and then I gave up this is as
best as I can group it in terms of
visual programming tools there's a few
predecessors but in my experience the
predecessors come from actually digital
audio if some of you are familiar with
it like pure data and Maximus B or
authored by a chap called Miller phuket
who developed this visual programming
environment that is actually quite able
to support multiple protocols so for me
it became a bit of a swiss knife that i
used every time i needed multiple
protocol support in one and then there's
another group which is based on quartz
composes something that Apple developed
a few years back and that hasn't
received a lot of love the people at
Facebook developed something called
origami on top of it to test
applications in native OS and viewer
also from a group of enthusiasts users
of quartz composer is also a visual
programming environment and there's
noodle as touch designer which I grouped
because of their IOT capabilities but
touch designer is a much more
multi-purpose workhorse and then notch
and 4v probably more aimed at insane
graphic display capabilities so you
might ask so is this for people who
don't know how to code and the answer
would be in a way yes because you are
you're not coding you
programming visually but is it for
people who don't know how to program I
would not say so because you would get
into trouble the same way you would do
with any other coding language coming to
touch designer and I must make a
disclaimer I'm not in any way affiliated
to to touch designer makers I just like
the tool and I know the people who make
it a very nice bunch of people and
there's nothing wrong with that
it's a procedural architecture so
everything that you do effects a stream
of data in a chain
it has a great interoperability
connecting to other pieces of software
it delivers very high performance
graphics capability it is we are capable
it supports many camera sensors and
importantly as well to mention here it's
extensible through script languages such
as Python and 3.5 for people who program
shaders and has GLSL 3.3 and for people
who don't find in the family of
operators that it provides an operator
that suits their needs they can program
them in C++ it supports many protocols
mqtt DMX MIDI OSC UDP artnet WebSockets
etc and it's available for Windows and
Mac OS one of the things that people
point out that these languages is what I
call the spaghetti monster effect but
you start programming visually and
because you're using space things can
get messy but then it's down to the
programmer to tied it up because it's in
an interface like that's designer for
example you can encapsulate your your
ideas and your your network so that as
they are called and you can structure
and make
libraries in a way so it doesn't need to
get like this even though the patches
that I might be showing later do you
look a little bit like this because I
don't I'm a messy guy but I think the
the highlights or the the strong points
would be that it fast fast tracks the
design process because the speed of
development means developing ideas is
phenomenal I think compared to other
methods it's a good common ground I
think for both designers and developers
because even if you have a team of
designers who look at it as something a
bit exotic at least you are able to
discuss how things will work and then
they will implement it in the chosen
tool for language testing is simpler and
I think it encourages experimentation
and experimentation is an important
level of creativity so and I think
developers are extremely creative people
as well and I think there's been quite a
few exciting exchanges of ideas while
trying these things out I think it also
enables an early detection of any
potential challenges for example
regarding feasibility and it's cheap
because it's fast to do it it doesn't
come at a very high price so I wanted to
cover after this very quick intro a few
examples of projects where I've used
visual programming languages in
particular touch designer one of them is
occupied by an oil company Norwegian who
needed to develop a new way to browse
their insane amount of data on the
Norwegian continental shelf and this is
done usually through web-based maps but
there's a lot of data that can only be
visualized in 3d
and one of the major problem is actually
how to find all the data how to browse
it and maps seem like a good way of
doing it because these are geo-located
assets that they have around the coast
but we need to combine it with a search
and we need to combine it with 3d
capabilities so the the prototype that
I'm going to show very quickly is a very
low fidelity meaning the visuals are
ugly I wasn't very concerned about the
visuals at this stage but I was
concerned about functionality regarding
testing some initial user experience
ideas that we had to get detailed
insight on particularly the search
interaction before starting to develop
the logic of that search and gain
validation from stakeholders in the
project of whether this was a good route
to go because it would it would mean
some investment in the project and then
of course discuss ideas with developers
and agree on implementation I suppose a
way to visualize it would be that we had
on one hand - the maps served via map
box married with a 3d engine and
developed the unity and we needed to
create a good user interface to enable
the two to particular design problems
that this prototype was looking at was
how to go from a simple search to an
assisted search where it's already
picking up what it has which matches
which terms match the database and from
that to a cumulative search where you
keep adding tags to your search that
become this and that and whatever this
is quite difficult to do in static
clickable prototypes so I resorted to
touch the designer to try those ideas
out and testing with users
the other thing that was trying to do
was to have what we call camera
bookmarks as because this happens in the
3d world and we are able to create
bookmarks for any camera position so you
can create your own presentation like a
walkthrough of your own exploration of
the map to reveal later so let's let's
have a look at the prototype then maybe
I'll need to do like this so here I'm
inside a touch designer environment I'm
going to try to do this while looking
sideways let's see how that works I
basically have a bunch of programs lined
up waiting to be awakened so I have a
very rough idea there is a map there is
a search box there's a lot of terms when
you don't search anything it reveals
everything I can I have a very sort of
crude mechanism of dragging it around
and adding bookmarks to to what I'm
doing
exploring further zooming in and out and
I wasn't very concerned about the looks
of it at this stage but it was just to
test whether I could express these ideas
to a user whether they thought it made
sense and one of the things was really
the ability to search and I couldn't
afford it to have developed to involve a
developer at this stage I just wanted to
test the idea so I did did that in touch
designer because I could easily create a
bunch of tables with rows of data which
would be then searchable but it's
something that you kind of build from
scratch of course so I can search for
company and add it to a sort of
available tax area here and then it will
highlight something on the map that's
all very good and I can search for maybe
something else there's a field called
scarve I can add it as well to the
search and it will tell me a little bit
about a field called scarve and very
good and then we tested another idea
because this is not unity but it also
ignores in 3d and just to be able to get
feedback from users of whether they
thought let if looking at the seabed in
a grid like this would make sense just
to reveal assets I don't remember now am
i al here it is where we would make
sense to pull out any of these assets to
look at the geology of it as a
cross-section so we were able to collect
a lot of feedback from geologists and
map users and people who work with very
detailed requirements the in the oil
business
about whether this would be a good way
to then have pull outs and information
looking at all of these things so the
result was that so inside you see that I
have sort of encapsulated a few UI
elements and just going to show very
quickly how this is done in case you are
wondering so I have a bunch of elements
here that are my tags and they are
selecting basically from the search from
a table that I created back here
so I could have a table with companies I
could have a table with facilities and
very quickly build a search it's nothing
amazing but it it's just done in minutes
and that's quite for a designer that's
quite an appealing proposition I would
say the end result is at a moment in
pilot mode it's been done for Windows
Mac OS and iOS and I have a little
vision video that shows the interface
here and there
[Music]
so the idea yes is that all the data is
stored in the cloud and then pulled in
[Music]
and this is the aspect of the search so
the idea was also that you could build
your own presentations through your
bookmark facilities as we call them
slides but they're mostly screen
positions in the 3d space where you can
add your own annotations
[Music]
so there's like a presentation mode in
the vision for the final product yes and
there's me
[Music]
and then the 3d exploration mode with
real geology information so quite
different from my prototype but just to
give you an idea of where we were going
with this
so was it a good idea or was it a good
choice for this I think so
I mean she's about using a programming
language I think it gave us a quick way
to test ideas with a functionality level
that's usually not available for
designers I will require databases and
screen capture management that I
couldn't do in another way it was made
in one day so that's quite quite a
simple way of testing an idea it enabled
me to invest time where it mattered
which was a question of how to deal with
search we take search as a very
matter-of-fact urge thing but it's quite
a lot of complexity that can go into it
and communication because it did play an
important role in discussing the
feasibility of ideas with developers and
other stakeholders the other example I
have to show you is a very simple
project for DNV GL where they wanted to
develop a chat bot
for the chat bot with real artificial
intelligence or actually specifically
machine learning ability running in the
background and this was served it was
already running as a pilot is being
served with Microsoft Azure technology
but what they didn't have was really a
good design for the for the character of
course you can take one of the standard
things but I wanted to do with something
a bit better than that so we wanted to
develop the look and feel something that
was character based to begin with that
was the idea we wanted to test the
usability of it gain validation from
everybody involved in the project and
provide documentation for developers so
it started
playing around with his character making
a few sketches of how this could look
like and went from something fairly
neutral looking to something warm and
then something a bit more graphic
I suppose the inspiration for this was
to marry or like the client says
something between Cortana and Siri okay
so that was more or less the reason why
we started playing around with these
shapes and thinking of how it would
behave in terms of movement and response
to your own voice and to its own voice
the the prototype had a codename called
Vera and I did I made a very very
quickly in touch designer so let's have
a look
there is sleeping here hope yeah so we
have a sort of a shape that is
responsive in real-time to sound and
this is something that is very easy to
do in touch designer and I cannot try to
do something that is a little bit risky
because the routing of sound can get a
bit funny when you come on stage and
connect different things but let's see
if it goes okay so I made just to
express to the stakeholders and
developers how this could work
[Music]
not only the animation and response and
the way the colors and shapes deformed
to the voice but also how the dialogues
could appear so made sort of a scripted
dialogue to to demo this hello Vera can
you hear me Vera can you hear me can you
hear me Vera
you can't hear back there but did you
hear a voice yeah that's the risky thing
about doing this on stage but open the
watertight doors Mira what's the problem
you guys sing this song so the prototype
is basically comprised and I've exposed
the network so it's it is a bit of a
spaghetti monster but I've exposed the
network so that I could just show the
different elements so there is elements
of sounds that is being processed the
audio the audio wave is causing the
distortion of basic ellipsis and through
that I'm able to then break it down in
different colors and overlap them to
become the shape that you see in the
renderer which is basically so different
stages so there is a bit of processing
pipeline that adds dialog boxes etc
there's my audio button but basically
the each shape has a green there's blue
and the yellowish shape that overlap
become that sort of entity for Vera
it's not called Vera in the end but
never mind that so I made some user
testing with my son he is trying it out
so I think even a three-year-old can can
be a good test subject the design
process per se and this enabled us to to
basically convey the basic elements of
what this entity this character which
was a more abstract shape now could be
and deliver them to developers and tell
them these are the final colors how it
would be on idle mode active and peak
what will be the animation parameters
etc so in recap
I think the real-time or the processing
ability and the animation capabilities
of touch designer helped me do this
quite fast it was made in one day
and then not the the dialogue part that
took a bit longer but he actually
animation and getting the colors right
was quite fast investing time were it
mattered which actually the look the
look infield of that character and it's
it's quite difficult to do this with
static designs so how do you explain
motion and behavior to anyone which it
static designs so it was a very good
tool to resort to to be able to do this
and communication because they became
the foundation for design specs and
actually it helped selling the idea
internally so that it could actually
become pilot project finally an
experiment which is a core dashboard
little experiment I've done just to play
around with the notion of being able to
interact with graphics with external
devices and since this is an embedded
more embedded themed conference I don't
think there's anything more embedded
than the software that we find in cars
today becoming more and more complex and
they have quite sophisticated machinery
in them
and program running so I tested
something that was just an internal
graphic system that could have
interchangeable modes just focusing on
the speed dial on the speed speedometer
as he call it and the export
possibilities of an integrated fully
dynamic system the idea was to
potentially connect it to sensors
actuators real-life physical interfaces
and we all have these complicated
instruments inside modern cars so it was
just to try out that that idea here at
the conference I don't have a way to
bring a steering wheel or an accelerator
pedal so I brought this too to be able
to communicate with that patch which is
just a MIDI Wireless MIDI interface that
I will try to use to control it so let's
look at touch designer again I'm going
to get out of this very patch and put it
to sleep
and I think my car dashboard is here so
I just focus on that
speedometer shape which I
there's no graphics being loaded into it
everything is generated internally so
every single little shape I drew it
programmatically or procedural in a
procedural way and I just did something
that is ability to switch modes from
[Music]
daytime to nighttime mode and different
camera positions just to get a feel for
what it will look like to be able to
separate the different layers of the
that comprise this interface so in touch
designer because it supports many
different protocols eat of course it
also supports MIDI and I have just to
check so I have this keyboard here that
is sending MIDI signals for the purpose
of testing this and then it's a matter
of mapping out which MIDI signals you
want to connect to what and I think well
I did is if I had an accelerator pedal
like it speed to let's say around 80
let's break the law 200 T and I also
have like a mode where this is yeah I'm
pressing from here now so if I had
different modes on my car dashboard I
could do it from there and the ability
to change this from a sort of automatic
counter to sort of manual counter and I
think I put different camera positions
here as well
so that I could do the same thing from
this little MIDI controller so just to
test the concept of being able to
interact with graphics that are can be
running in any kind of screen so if if I
had the right conditions I could connect
this to a instrument panel and have any
sort of actuator or a sensor triggering
these same signals that I'm doing with a
silly MIDI controller I can do a short
dive into this one just to show the
spaghetti monster within so this a lot
of stuff going on here I mean like you
can see the the numbers are being drawn
and different shapes that make the
different effects I have let's see I can
show the final renderer at this end sort
of any operator can be can be viewed as
a renderer so I have a table here for
exons with RGB values sort of
destination and origin RGB values I
remember which one it is now this one so
in you saw that there was a slight delay
but the delay is being applied to the to
the to the numbers just to get
transition effect and a smooth effect
between them so anything that I'm doing
any any design aspect that I want to
change I can change it in real time
that's basically the main point going
back to the presentation
we've looked at the prototype I think it
the interesting thing about this is the
inbound and outbound communication
ability and to be able to do that with
any type of graphics in real-time is
interesting for many projects and the
fact that you can have real-time
generated graphics nothing being
imported in makes it quite a good
standalone system that you can take
anywhere and made it in three days where
I had it coupled in with different types
of sensors and just to tune in and get
the animations right and I think it has
a very good level of efficiency because
once the graphics are drawn they can be
I can control every single aspect that
is on that little speedometer maybe a
bit of a geeky thing to do but I think
it's just a proof of concept so to wrap
it up the upsides in my mind for using
visual programming tools is that it fast
tracks the design process because the
speed is just phenomenal I think it's a
good common ground for designers and
developers even though some these some
developers consider this to be toy
programming it's actually quite powerful
so if there is one uptake for you if you
have never used a visual programming
language is if it's being proposed by a
designer try not to roll your eyes and
explore the possibility I think testing
is simpler because you don't need to
pester the the developers too much
before you try out things that might not
work you realize it yourself or they
might point it out for you I think it
encourages experimentation and that's
that's a very important element of
creativity and I think because it's
cheap it's a small investment that can
yield very important results the
downside to be perfectly honest is
there's there's a few that are
classically pointed out
like visual programming languages can
have a steep learning curve discipline
is needed because you can get caught in
the exploration loop we can be exploring
and experimenting forever if you don't
if you're not careful because it's just
so absorbed I suppose that happens with
developers do but at some point you need
to chop it off
so some detachment is necessary kill
your darlings and your your prototypes
and move on into the real world when
when the stage has come and I'm not
selling the speed as everything as the
only element faster is not necessarily
better but it is it is a good resort
when you just want to try out an idea
and of course the the the nature of
visual programming language or tools can
lead to these spaghetti monsters but
that's up to we can have messy code to
write that is covering many many more
lines than needed I think the same thing
applies to visual programming languages
wow I managed to finish on time thank
you I'll be posting an article soon so
if you want to follow me on LinkedIn
it's my name born in 73 and I think I
have a colleague later on from eggs if
you want to if you're interested in
other design matters he'll be doing a
presentation for designing for consumers
succeeding with professionals thank you
very much yeah
[Music]
yes and no I mean you're able to you're
able to export curves you're able to
export different types of assets and
rendered elements but if I understand
your question correctly no not like that
not to bootstrap oh wait yes well if you
if you are aiming to integrate this into
a development pipeline for real I mean
I'm presenting this as just a testbed
for ideas that you can discuss with
developers not to take materially as
code but there are products developed
and running with this but what is then
done is to separate different elements
and you can have like I I mentioned you
can have Python running in it and those
can be does those elements can be shared
among development teams and they can
contribute so it can be a much more
Python based network than that that I
showed yeah
anything
almost so far it's almost any I mean not
not exotic picture image formats but it
supports anything pngs gave PS DS Tiff's
is actually the the the object that
brings in images is called movie file in
and the name is telling you that it also
it's the same object it doesn't care if
it's an image file or a video file so as
long as it's in the supported list and
you will find that in the derivative
page the file formats that are supported
but this is I think it's all the normal
ones you would you would need to use of
course there's nothing else asking
questions so yeah construct elements
it depends on what but like to create
those like to create those little those
little round petals that I had around
the dashboard that speedometer dial I
basically described the shape once with
with actually geometries you're just
describing a geometry you saying I want
half a circle only the outline and then
you inverted at the other end and then
you say connected to boom and then from
that you say I want to repeat it so many
times and even that repetition and the
angle and the parade the upper very odd
the number of petals that you have in
within the circle is it 50 is a 30 is it
15 it's all defined programmatically
after you've done that just to take that
example